[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans la grande
interview
aujourd'hui nous avons le plaisir
d'avoir le premier ministre de la
république centrafricaine bonjour la
première question que je voudrais vous
poser c'est sur la coopération russo
centrafricaine donc quel bilan tirez
vous justement de cette coopération qui
à vrai qu avocat eut un autre élan
depuis 2018 je voudrais remercier la la
presse qui est dans notre enfance pour
qu'on parle
au terme de cette visite de travail
spécifiquement sur la question
l'état de la coopération de mon pays et
la fédération de russie
l'état de la coopération est très bon
mais je voudrais rappeler que cette
coopération ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
nous entretenons de très bonnes
relations de coopération avec la
fédération de russie depuis le début de
nos indépendances et cette coopération
s'est beaucoup développée dans les
années 70 dans beaucoup de domaines y
compris même celui de l'enseignement
aujourd'hui à l affermissement de cette
coopération est en venant moscou sur
l'invitation du gouvernement de la
fédération de russie je suis venu au nom
du réseau là le public bon celui du
gouvernement donc exprimer notre
gratitude
à la fédération de russie pour tout
l'appui politique sécuritaire militaire
aussi qu'elle nous apporte et qui nous
permet aujourd'hui d'avancer et donc
cette condamnation
elle se porte bien dans quel domaine
entendez vous élargir les relations
russo centrafricaine
aujourd'hui au plan de la sécurité
nous avons connu des avancées je ne
reviendrai pas là dessus mais
aujourd'hui nous devons aussi sur les
questions de l'économie et des autres
secteurs productifs nous devons aussi
travailler avec la fédération de russie
je pense particulièrement au secteur du
commerce au secteur 2
des milles ce n'est pas un secret si
dans les autres pays du monde les états
peuvent vivre de l'exploitation de leurs
ressources naturelles
il n'y a pas de problème que en vue de
centre africaine que nous puissions
envisager cette possibilité dans le
cadre des lois de notre pays aussi dans
le domaine de l'agriculture vous savez
quand éric centrafricaine plus de 80% de
la population est rurale est donc
aujourd'hui il nous faut sur l'autorité
du président de la république donner et
donner des perspectives donc à cette
population rurale surtout d'envisager
l'encadrement de l'agriculture un début
de mécanisation en termes de soutien à
ce
du monde rural qui s'organisent en
coopérative il ya cela il ya également
l'autre le secteur de l'énergie
notamment l'électricité et des autres
branches de l'énergie donc nous sommes
venus parler de toutes ces questions
économiques pour voir qu'est ce qu'il
est possible de faire dans les années à
venir
mais cette on peut dire la proximité
entre la centrafrique et la russie a
parfois suscité des critiques de la part
de la diplomatie française par exemple
jean yves le drian a plusieurs fois
critiqué cette proximité entre la russie
à la centrafrique
comment réagiriez-vous assez critique
justement on à m'écouter
le président de la république chef de
l'état a évoqué ce sujet personnellement
je l'évoqué même à deux reprises sur
radio france internationale et autres il
ya de la place pour tout le monde
en république centrafricaine pourquoi
est ce que dans les autres pays on ne
parle pas de cela nous avons des amis
traditionnels
la russie fait partie de nos amis
traditionnels nous dirigent et je vous
ai dit que c'est depuis le début des
indépendances que nous entretenons des
relations de coopération
il y a de la place pour tout le monde en
république centrafricaine il faut pas
diaboliser et diaboliser le la
coopération l'alberta avec certains de
ses partenaires que tout le monde
devienne ce que nous voulons que tout le
monde vienne en république
centrafricaine ils nous aident à
travailler à nous émanciper à donner des
éléments de réponse précise aux besoins
de notre peuple
les querelles sur les fréquentations les
débats politiciens nous n'en voulons pas
si certaines puissances si certains pays
veulent se faire la guerre ou se
détester b qui se parlent entre eux mais
c'est que certains et je le dis sous
l'autorité du présent la république il a
déjà dit nous sommes pour la
multiplication ne sont pas pour la
division et ça c'est une thèse que le
chef de l'état défend que tous les amis
du pays viennent nous aider à nous en
sortir
il ya de la place pour tout le monde
pourquoi pourquoi se focaliser que sur
la rue les syndicats en afrique il ya
beaucoup de pays qui entretiennent des
relations diplomatiques
concomitamment avec beaucoup d'états
pourquoi cette cristallisation sur la
démo centrafricaine donc chez nous ce
débat nous l'ont voulu
nous sommes prêts à travailler avec tout
le monde dans le sens de la recherche
des éléments de réponse à apporter aux
préoccupations de notre peuple
il ya aussi la france a exhorté à
l'afrique à faire bloc avec quelle face
à des tentatives de prédation comment
percevez-vous cet appel et surtout 80
ans après le manifeste du général de
gaulle est ce qu il peut toujours y
avoir un destin commun avec la france
vous savez madame la france est notre
partenaire historique
nous avons des relations privilégiées
avec la france jusqu'aujourd'hui la
france nous aide énormément
voyez vous même au plan politique la
plupart des résolutions adoptées par le
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
nous l'avons obtenu avec le soutien de
la france puisque c'est la france qui
est la plume de 2 dans ce cadre là haut
niveau des nations unies le soutien de
la france avec 200 dates qui ne nous
fait pas défaut donc pour nous n'avons
pas de projet avec la france maintenant
les autres débats en trouverez les
cadres pour les évoquer ce qui est
certain nous ne parlons pas publiquement
des questions qui relèvent la politique
française mais nous savons que la france
nous aide à améliorer certaines
questions qui sont nécessaires au
développement de notre pays y compris la
question politique mais on ne veut pas
être embarrassé aussi sur certaines
questions que certains de nos options ne
soit pas autrement perçu comme je viens
de l'évoquer aujourd'hui le monde a
changé le monde a évolué nous sommes
conscients que certains amis seul ne
peut pas nous aider apporter toutes les
réponses à nos questions de
développement
par conséquent il ne faut pas regarder
autrement notre démarche
quant à la diversification de notre
partenariat
on veut avoir un partenaire dynamique
avec tout le monde pour autant nous
sommes pressés de donner des éléments de
réponse aux préoccupations de notre
peuple et dans tous les secteurs
voilà pour passer aux autres sujets qui
inquiètent je pense le monde entier
c'est la pandémie du courant d'un virus
donc qu'on vous le savez la pandémie
sévit dans tout le monde dans le monde
entier
comment le pays fait face justement à
cette pandémie
vous savez comme les autres pays du
monde
depuis le fin février début mars
nous sommes préoccupés par cette
pandémie qui est mondial
alors heureusement dans mon pays le
présent la république a pris le
leadership
quant à la prise en charge de cette
question il ya des dispositifs
institutionnels qui ont été mis en place
un comité de crise que le présent la
république plaisait lui-même auquel
assiste donc tous les partenaires du
pays et comités techniques que je dirige
la délégation du président de la
république pour si avec tous les
partenaires du pays et donc au jour le
jour nous essaierons de faire le point
de la situation pour voir quel type de
réponses apportées devant cette cette
crise sanitaire qui menace la santé
mondiale et dans ce cadre là nous avons
nous étions amenés donc à prendre un
certain nombre de mesures de restriction
au niveau national
entre autres exemples à un moment on a
fermé les aéroports
à l'exemple des autres pays du monde on
a réduit certaines libertés notamment
certains regroupements au delà d'un
certain nombre de personnes donc au
niveau national on va essayer de prendre
certains de mes yeux au début la
situation était très préoccupante on
enregistrait 100 à 150 cas d'infection
par jour des cas de décès mme avec tout
le travail fait par le gouvernement
selon les directives données par le
président de la république je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il se passe parfois
quelques jours on ne connaît pas de on
n'a pas des informations sur des
nouvelles cartes des nouveaux cas de
contamination du décès je pense que à
l'exemple de certains pays nous essayons
de maîtriser la situation mieux aussi
avec le soutien de la communauté
internationale puisque nous avons aussi
bénéficié des appuis du fonds monétaire
international des institutions sous
régionales
quant à la prise en charge donc de la
riposte à cette pandémie au niveau
national pour conduire continuons peu
sûres
les affaires intérieures du pays
notamment sur l'accord de paix avec les
groupes armés entre les groupes armés et
le gouvernement
oui comment voyez vous l'avenir de cet
accord est ce que pour vous cet accord
est solide et ce que vous êtes optimiste
quand à quant à la préservation de cet
accord surtout en vue de la
présidentielle
madame écoutez je pense que le présent
dans les pubs les chefs de l'état a fait
le meilleur choix en signant cet accord
puisque si on n'avait pas cet accord
on aurait pu avoir la guerre il est
connu que plus d'une année après
l'accord politique pour la paix la
réconciliation
la situation sécuritaire est au centre
de l'accord politique pour la paix la
réconciliation cette situation s'est
beaucoup améliorée
vous pouvez en juger à travers la
lecture du dernier rapport un produit
par le conseil de sécurité des nations
unies et on constate que sur le terrain
il ya quand même des exactions exactions
des violences est donc est ce que ça
vous fait pour ce fait qu' il ya quand
même toujours les des dites madame renée
que la signature d'un accord de paix
n'est pas la paix donc nous les pays du
monde
après la signature de l'accord de paix
s'il ya tout un processus qu'il faut
mettre en place les gens ne parlent que
de ce qui ne semble pas marcher
mais dans le cas de mon pays cet accord
de paix aujourd'hui nous a apporté
beaucoup de résultats significatifs et
j'en veux pour preuve aujourd'hui sont
maintenant de faire de progrès sur
l'autorité du président de la république
en matière de désarmement en matière de
désarmement
savez vous est ce que vous savez que
pendant la transition qui a dû de quatre
années on n'a pas fait le désarmement
on n'a pas connu un début de désamour
grâce à l'accord politique pour la paix
la réconciliation aujourd'hui nous avons
commencé le désarmement dans plusieurs
parties du pays notamment au nord ouest
au centre est à kaga bandoro habile à
eau
nous avons commencé le désarmement délit
sans l'accord de paix on n'aurait pas eu
cette accalmie avec le groupe armé pour
commencer à retirer les armes qui sont
en circulation et qui entretiennent
l'insécurité dans le pays
alors si vous voulez notre avis nous
sommes confiants nous sommes confiantes
que avec une bonne mise en oeuvre de
l'accord politique pour la paix la
réconciliation
on obtiendrait des bons résultats
surtout en matière de sécurité c'est que
nous permettrait donc de nous consacrer
aux uns ou aux autres tâches de
développement sur lesquels notre peuple
nous attend au lendemain mais concernant
l'élection présidentielle est-ce qu'il
va se tenir à la date annoncée ou est-ce
que les préparatifs vont bon train
actuellement
absolument aujourd'hui le l'autorité
nationale des élections quelle
institution chargée de préparer et
d'organiser les élections et
agit donc dans les délais à l'instant où
nous échangeons l'autorité nationale des
élections vient de terminer donc
l'enregistrement des électeurs
nous sommes actuellement dans une phase
de gestion des réclamations et du
contentieux
le plaisant la république vient de
signer deux décrets l'un convoquant le
corps électoral
pour le 27 décembre 2020 ce qui
correspondrait donc au premier tour des
élections
et puis le second décret dont qui fixe
le découpage électoral le présent la
république le gouvernement tenait au
respect des délais constitutionnels
évidemment nous essayons avec tous les
partenaires du pays qui sont présents
nous essayons de créer les conditions
d'appuyer une autorité nationale des
élections à obtenir les conditions
d'organiser des élections crédibles
transparentes transparents ou résultat
irréprochable et de sécurisation de
faire merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à
nos questions
merci ça moi de vous remercier et
surtout de m'avoir donné l'occasion de
parler sous l'autorité du président la
république au nom de mon pays
[Musique]